what up boys i'm back early a day early
because i'm passed i got to make this
video real quick
regular videos start tomorrow expect
that
but i i gotta talk about this sec hunts
for fraud in social media posts
hyping gamestop aka you post on
wall street banks be careful uh it's
time the sec is coming after you expect
some jail time baby
and you know we gotta talk about this
because it's flies
in the face of what the sec should be
doing here
they've got limited manpower okay i get
it they got
limited time so why are you going to
spend your time
looking at a bunch of brain dead
redditers no offense
i'm one of you okay relax when you could
be looking at
these p these billionaire hedge funds
who've managed to just
escape away or they're trying to with
the help of people like
robin hood who's restricting trades
meanwhile in the exact same article
where they announced quote
uh securities and exchange commission
investigators are combing social media
and extreme message boards posts for
signs that fraud
played a role in the dizzying stock
swings for gamestop
according to people familiar with the
matter okay nice little anonymous thing
in that same exact breath that they're
saying hey guys
we're getting the magnifying glass uh
wall street bets we're coming for you
in the same breath that they're coming
after a bunch of redditors
they are apparently uh talking to a
former sec council
who says oh yeah the robin hood what
robin hood did definitely not illegal
we've already thought about it we're not
illegal
tom what do you make of robin hood
actions here because they're now facing
lawsuits did robin hood do anything
illegal here or fraudulent probably not
not certainly not by restr look at the
astro turfing campaign
going on before your very eyes let me be
clear about what they're saying
you're the bad guy hey you traitor at
home
you know with your 600 stimmy your
stimulus check
you're the bad guy you've committed a
cri you may have committed a crime the
sec is looking into you they're
taking a very careful look at you
meanwhile
these scumbags that robinhood who he
says oh it wasn't our fault oh it was
the clearinghouse
okay well did the clearinghouse do
anything wrong oh no no no no it wasn't
them no no no conspiracy
the guy calls it a conspiracy the robin
hood guy look at this this is when elon
musk was talking with uh the ceo of
robin hood
you have a strong say in who got
put in charge of that organization since
it's an industry consortium not a
government consortium or not a
government regulatory agency
um i i don't have any reason to believe
that i think that's just like
you know then you're getting into kind
of the conspiracy theories a little bit
so i just have no no reason to believe
that that's the case you know
yeah guys uh listen hey
look don't get into conspiracy theories
what are you saying something fishy
happened
oh sec is not gonna look into it guys
sec
spending their time looking into you
guys over on wall street bets baby
these guys they're you guys over here
are criminals look at you
look at you 8.5 million
criminals that's we're gonna change that
uh good luck
i mean i'm subscribed too so i i may be
in trouble myself
um but let's just remember right let's
just remember what happened
do you guys remember in 2008 when only
one banker
went to jail this is that all over again
you guys remember when pogo in 2013
project on government oversight released
the thing about how the sec has risk of
regulatory capture in other words
they're owned by the people that they're
supposed to be regulating in other words
if they ever were faced with a series of
fraud they couldn't investigate it
because
the people who control them are the very
people they should be investigating oh
yeah but guys don't
don't look into this this is a big
conspiracy la la land
fun times it's just yet another uh story
that when big hedge fund managers
manipulate the market oh
it's just them doing their job but when
wall street bets gets a hold of the fact
that a stock is shorted over a hundred
percent and they take advantage of it
well you guys may have broken the law
guys you guys are being investigated
let's not forget that we have hedge fund
managers on record like jim cramer
admitting that they would do illegal
things
guys they would do illegal things and
they still were not investigated
why well the sec doesn't understand it
they hit a lot of guys with rim
now you can't ferment that's a violation
of vermilion yeah
you can't foment you can't create a
yourself an impression that a stock's
down
this is jim cramer back in the day
talking about what he would do as a
hedge fund manager he's basically saying
you can't manipulate the market but then
listen to what he says
but you do it anyway because the sec
doesn't understand it so yeah
oh wait what was that again hot on sorry
jim go back the stock's down
but you do it anyway because the sec
doesn't understand it you do it anyway
because the sec doesn't understand it
they don't understand it or they don't
want to understand it because they're
too busy
looking around for a bunch of people at
home with their stimulus checks
and investigating them rather than
investigating
the hedge funds the broker houses
everybody who
magically seems to be lining up all
the dominoes in order to screw you and
benefit the billionaires but guys don't
look into it if you do
hey we all know who you are alex jones
propellants
you know insect repellents people lather
themselves with
and then you can protect your head from
the sun so you don't get
see how fast i did that folks i'm an
expert every day when i leave
work i do this let's do a wide shot guys
people see the full power
um i i don't have any reason to believe
that i think that's just like
you know then you're getting into kind
of the conspiracy theories a little bit
so i just have no no reason to believe
that that's the case you know